foreign
that's what we did last lecture
we're we're going to move on today but I
want to just clarify something about
Vesper
um when I was talking about this I I
tried to put two different concepts in
the same place and I put something in
the table that shouldn't have been there
and and people corrected me I want to be
sure that there's no confusion around
this
so what we had was a case of
formaldehyde
right
and
we had the case of
SO2
and I want to be really clear about this
both of these molecules when you're
thinking about Vesper the number the
number
of electron domain count right remember
that's how we start the number of of
electron domains is the same
for both of them right and we we did
this on on Wednesday
right and and if the number of electron
domains is the same then the electron
domain geometry is trigonal planar
right
okay
but
I was
also telling you about repulsion order
at the same time
and and so I put I I put the wrong thing
in the table and then I erased it I just
want to be sure we're clear and we don't
get bent out of shape about it stop get
out of here stop stop it all right all
right I'm gonna still be here I'm gonna
be here all right so like here right the
shape
remember what the table
what the table
was about
was the number of Lone pairs
okay the number of Lone Pairs and so if
I've got the three bonding Pairs and no
lone pairs then it's going to be a
trigonal planar shape so that is
trigonal planar
and over here I've got two bonding Pairs
and one lone pair and so this shape is
called bent now what I did is I used
that word ah why I don't know but you
know you make mistake when you're in the
arena
you keep going and if you make a mistake
you admit it you leave it all there
you do your best forget the rest that's
all you can ever do
now here's the thing I said bent I said
the word bent and what I was talking
about was how that bends a little bit
because of the repulsion order yeah but
that that shape is Not Bent I want to be
real clear about that that shape is
trigonal planar and it's a little bit
distorted
okay
this shape is bent
that shape is bent and because it's a
it's got a lone pair remember the shape
is about where the atoms are right but
it's also a little bit distorted
right because the lone pair pushes on
those guys a little bit more
all right okay so that those are the two
concepts that I was
saying all at once and I want to make
sure we understand them there's trigonal
planar there's bent and then there's
repulsion order which talks about a
little changes in the angle from those
parent shapes okay good all right now
on to today now here's the thing now in
in all this stuff with Lewis
it's a really good way to think about
molecules
but this tells me that there's electrons
on the bond it tells me that there's
electrons really localized in the region
between the atoms but see the thing is
how much is it localized
how much is it really is it are these
electrons like you know
what if I were to draw the two electrons
so those dots like right there
it doesn't really tell me the info more
information than that
but if we remember the the the picture
let's see if I can pull yeah there it is
there's a picture I showed you when we
first talked about covalent bonds
sharing is caring remember what happens
I've got the two protons and we talked
about these a repulsion and then the two
electrons repulsion and then I drew for
you the fact that but they can come
together and they can be like you know
what you can use my proton for a little
of your attraction and hey can I use
your you know and they share it and each
electron sees both of them and this is
where those electrons are but look at
that the proton is there and there and
the electron is in this probability
Cloud around both of them that's the
molecular
orbital
and Lewis can't tell us about that so we
need something else and that's what
today's topic is about today we're going
to talk about something called molecular
orbital theory that gives us a sense of
how these
Atomic orbitals
overlap
it gives us a much
it gives us a much better and more deep
a deeper description with more details
about these covalent bonds okay all
right now so let's write a few things
about molecular orbital Theory oh
molecular orbital and what we're going
to do is say mo
a molecular orbital Theory so we'll keep
a list of some important things all
right well the first of all the first
thing is that Atomic orbitals
Atomic orbitals
or
as we may call them AOS
are the basis
for watch this efficiency the Mo's I
didn't have to write it again right okay
so what does that mean well it means
that I'm going to construct
the Mo's from the AOS now the AOS are
the things we've been playing with and
making right we solved the Schrodinger
equation so the Mo's
okay are going to be linear
combinations
all right combinations
of
the AOS and that's why you might see
this in fact
called lcao Theory lcao linear
combination of atomic orbitals
okay
and in particular
some and difference
of orbitals is what we're about because
you know this is like what we talked
about before uh
these are waves
right these are waves waves can can
either constructively or destructively
interfere
and that's what we're going to explore
in MO Theory by adding or subtracting
these wave functions these orbitals
these Atomic orbitals
so that's enough to start let's see so
look basis a basis is nothing more than
the things that I'm going to use to
represent the things that I want
right and the things that I want are
these molecular orbitals the things that
I'm going to use to represent those are
these
these beautiful Atomic orbitals
that we spend a lot of time
understanding and developing
we'll start with the simplest case
which is
what I think I have
oh I even highlighted it and I said
let's first make molecular orbitals
using
combinations of the S orbital that's the
S orbital that's the 1s orbital up there
remember by the way
blue and orange is just a sign of the
wave right this is not a charge please
don't make that uh that confusion these
are just waves right waves okay and the
p orbital has let's go back and see it p
orbital has a plus and a minus it's a
wave all right and the S the 2s orbital
has that too then you square it and you
get the probabilities right
okay so we'll start with 1s where it's
all just one sign and I can add it
I can add an s in another s or I can
subtract it so let's do that right so
we'll do that over here
all right oh
so we'll do that over here
so if I take a 1s
orbital
and I add it to another 1s orbital well
you can see as I bring these close
together
if they have the same sign these are
waves so if I if I if the waves are both
positive and I bring them together they
can constructively interfere so as I
bring them closer and closer well I
might actually get the picture that I
showed you right I might actually get
something
that looks like this
okay I might actually get something like
this now if I if I subtracted them
then as I bring these
as I bring these orbitals closer
together
uh they're going to cancel each other
and you can see right here if I bring
these orbitals by the way which are
coming from two different atoms right
the whole point is we're talking about
molecules molecular
so if I bring them together now like
this but I'm subtracting these orbitals
then you can see that right at the
interface right between them it's always
zero
because I've just subtracted the same
amount no matter how close they get is
zero that's a node
right and in fact what you're going to
get is something that looks like this
right
now so what I've done is I have
I have added and subtracted the same AO
and I've created two Mo's so these are
my MOS and these are my starting AOS
that's about the simplest thing you can
do in MO Theory
I'm using these as a basis now there's
something very important which is that
this is I kind of already alluded to
this these are two atoms coming together
to make a bond
this is the bonding axis
this is the bonding axis okay now if an
orbital if an MO
is symmetric okay so if it has
cylindrical
Celine
drical
symmetry
about that bonding axis
then
it's called the sigma orbital
it's called the sigma orbital that's the
mo
Sigma is a notation a sigma orbital is
one that has symmetry around the
inter-nuclear axis the two and ah
[Music]
we're coming to that
very soon
because these are just the orbitals I
got to do something with them it's just
like over here I made all these orbitals
but then I had to fill them
ah that got me excited
give me that but see you can see right
here when I add them up
when I add them up you there's charge in
between
so this looks like it's going to have a
bond
that's a bonding MO
what but if I subtracted them this
doesn't look very happy in terms of like
electrons being in between and the
carrying and sharing principle of a
covalent bond right so if I were to put
an electron in this Mo it doesn't look
bonding in fact it looks
or
anti-bonding it's actually not quite
non-bonding we'll get to that later this
would be anti
bonding why
because
there's not even a chance of electron
density in between yeah that's your
starting principle of the relationship
let's try to share oh by the way right
halfway no chance
that's not a very good way to start and
you can see why this is an antibody it's
the opposite you're actually pushing
charge away from the bond if you're in
this orbital if you're an electron in
that orbital that's an antibonding order
now we get to the the question
what do you do with these orbitals well
you make them
I made these with 1s
and the way that we typically draw this
as we go back to the same picture that
we've been working with One S here and
1s here
and I brought those orbitals together
and I formed one that lowered the energy
of the system and another
that actually raise the energy of the
system because the electrons are
repelling they're actually
less bonding they're anti-bonding right
so these are my Mo's
those are my AOS right a-o-a-o and and
now this is called a sigma orbital
and the way we refer to the anti-bonding
orbital is with the little star
they're both Sigma because they both
satisfy that right they're both Sigma
because they both have symmetry around
the inter-nuclear bonding axis but now
see okay so that's good
um
and
but now let's fill them let's fill them
right because now
um let's write let's write down the
rules and then we'll fill them for some
examples okay so I'm going to keep going
on my Mo Theory list right as you can
see when I do it this way the number of
Mo's equals the number of AOS
used
to
create them so that's one thing that we
can see right away right I use two AOS I
added and subtracted them I got two
ammos good another thing is
each MO
will
be just like an ale
right it makes a lot of sense I had room
for two electrons here
I had room for two electrons here I
gotta have room for four
two here two here
right so each MO
has a max
of two electrons
and they must obey Paulie
just like in EOS they must obey poly
get mess with quantum mechanics
still electrons are still quantum
mechanical
right you're just making their wave
function more sophisticated
but they still have to follow the
Schrodinger equation and the principles
of quantum mechanics and so finally what
we're going to do is we're going to fill
them so we're going to fill the Mo's
with electrons
starting with the lowest energy just
like we did for atoms lowest energy
first
okay
and one more thing just like we did with
Adam Adams is we're going to obey hunt
ah hunt Hun's rule which tells you about
how to fill degenerate orbitals well
we're going to have degenerate orbitals
here too we don't yet but we will so
we're going to fill them so let's let's
fill them for the very simplest cases
okay so we'll do some cases together
and
we'll see how that goes right so what
I'm going to do is four cases just so we
can compare so first
we're going to do H2 plus okay that's
that's the first one and here what we
have is the
same graph but now over here I actually
can label it now this is just an orbital
but now Gesundheit now is that okay well
this is the h
this would be like h
and H Plus
okay these are my Mo's Sigma Sigma star
1s 1s oh boy
but if I so if that's H and that's h
plus right and they're coming together
to make H2 plus that's what's in the
middle there that's the molecule right
well then I also can now fill in the
starting a O's so let's do that
um
that's it because this one lost somebody
had to lose an electron to start with
we'll just represent so now when these
come together you fill you you obey the
palette exclusion you fill from the
lowest energy first is that well I only
got one electron there it is
that's my Mo diagram populated by
electrons
okay
now there's a principle that comes out
of this there's a way of understanding
bond strength now
there's a way of understanding bouncing
and and that is a very important concept
now let's put it here in our list let's
put it here in our list
okay
and it's a concept called bond order
bond order now this one I really want to
write Bo but I don't know if that's good
a good idea
so I'm Gonna Keep
I got Laura that one okay and that's
gonna equal there's a definition for
this it's going to equal one half
of the number of electrons in a bonding
orbital in a bonding
orbital
minus the number of electrons in an
anti-bonding
anti-bonding
orbital sorry this is a little bit small
here
but we'll do a bunch of them so you can
see what this means right so that the
bond order is important because the bond
order of a molecule
right so the bond order Bond
order
if it's higher if it's higher
then
stronger Bond
and it has to be greater
and it has to be greater than zero for
stability
let's see let's see how that works and I
mean we'll we'll see this intuitively as
well as we fill these up all right so if
I count the bond order here oh I'm gonna
do it I don't feel like writing it out
the Bo on this one is a half
times one minus zero which equals a half
okay good
it's a half well it's greater than zero
so right away I know that the H2 plus
molecule is probably stable that's good
but let's go to some more examples now
let's do a few more
all right
now we're going to work our way to H2
and in this case energy is always going
up in these diagrams
now each of these H atoms
is bringing an electron there's no
charge to the system and so now
um
different quantum numbers poly
different Quantum but same Sigma right
and so now that's the H2 now the B the
bond order here
is equal to one
right I didn't have any electrons in an
antibonding orbital all right but you
know it's coming I'm going to do HE2
Plus next
and here what you're going to see is
okay if I were Let's do let's just put
it here for comparison in real time if I
were HE2
each of these would be the AO occupation
of an he atom
right
and but since I'm HE2 Plus one of them
is missing an electron so this is what
you're going to see these are both he
atoms still but one of them is is Plus
in this picture and but see now okay
I've got three electrons they're going
to go here I've got to put one up here
I have to
because I had three I got to keep on
filling just like in an atom
but now I'm feeling bonding and
anti-bonding orbitals all right and here
I've got this
and two up there
so if you look at the bond order here
the bond order is still positive
here the bond order is zero
and in fact that's why HE2 is not a
stable molecule
because you're putting just as much
charge on this thing that wants to bond
it as you are on this thing that doesn't
want to bond it
and at the end of the day it leads to a
molecule that is not stable
so that would be HE2 but HE2 Plus has a
bond order that's similar
right
that's similar did I get something wrong
HE2 Plus one half
okay now
because the this weakened it
right this weakened the molecule
compared to this because now I added
charge to an anti-bonding orbital so you
would expect from the bond order that
this one is more stable than this and in
fact that's what you find
right the H2 molecule has a stronger
bonding energy
now we can write the molecular orbital
configurations just like we did with the
atomic orbital configurations
okay and so like for here
ah
right so for this case
I'm going to write it up top if I can
finish so here we would have Sigma 1s
and we're populating it with
Ah that's not my example
um
this is my example
Sigma 1s is the orbital and we're
populating it with one electron right so
that's how we would write that now if we
go to the next examples
we would have this one is this molecule
you would write as Sigma 1s2
so this would be Sigma 1s
2. and oh now I've got Sigma 1s
two oh this is getting interesting
because now it's Sigma star
1s
1.
does everybody see that all right I
populate I mean this is just like spb
but
now I'm just filling those ammos up and
I'm I'm showing you what the molecular
configuration is
with those molecular orbital names Sigma
1s Sigma 1s star okay good
now
we can keep going
we can do this all day
um actually we kind of will but we're
going to move on don't worry from Sigma
um let's see let me go over here
now this is another concept that I want
you to know about Mo Theory so
if you know so if I kept going
I could have for example uh let's do
lithium
okay so now lithium 1s oh 2s
lithium brings this
what does it bring it brings three
electrons and over here
One S
and
2s three electrons so this would be the
lithium
dimer and but I want to make an
appointment when you
would draw this one
here's how I would draw it whereas when
I would draw this one I would draw it
like this
okay now those are supposed to be the
same spacing I'll tell you just want to
tell you in a second
um the this notice that the distance
here between the bonding and antibonding
interval is larger than it is here
the reason is because
it's related to the overlap
so there's another point which is that
the overlap
of AOS
is
related so the let's say the greater
the
greater
the overlap of AOS the greater
the
change in energy
between bonding and antibonding orbitals
ah
between bonding and antibonding orbitals
and let's be clear those are molecular
well see you can see like if I'm lithium
those 1s's aren't going to overlap too
much
right they're kind of close to the Core
so you do get Mo's there but the mo the
difference that you get depends on how
much these electrons are near in energy
and overlapping
right so so the 2s can overlap a lot
more
okay now if I were to fill this up we
would get something like this
it's all these Sigma 1s's
oh
Sigma 1 s what do you think these are
called
Sigma 2s
Sigma 2s Sigma 2s and this okay this is
getting a little bit I'm going to draw
this out here that's the sigma 1s star
right and this would be the sigma 2s
star
well what am I going to occupy well how
many electrons do I have to pour into
the molecular orbitals
um
lithium
lithium 2 is stable because it's bond
order is you say bond order number of
electrons in bonding orbitals one two
three four minus number of electrons and
antibondiors minus 1 2 divided by two so
the lithium dimer bonding order is one
all right and then you can go on and you
can say well if I had beryllium I'd have
another electron here and here and I'd
fill those antibonding orbitals up again
like in the HE2 timer and I would have
again an unstable molecule which is in
fact true
okay this is sort of the simplest way
you can think about molecular orbital
Theory because it's the simplest orbital
but you could go
you can you can spend the whole night
and it is a Friday
what else do you have this is what you
do on a pro
after I watch
Dr quantum
I'm gonna just add every single one of
these with every single one it's finite
it's not going to take forever
let's just do p
so okay now with P orbitals there's
something interesting that happens
because now that that sign you see how
the P has a plus and a minus right and
so you got to kind of think about that a
little bit
okay
if I take a p orbital
and I'm going to take a
I'm going to do it like this minus plus
and I'm going to add it to a p orbital
that looks like this and notice I'm
taking these and I'm adding them along
in axis where they're kind of both along
the axis
right they're both along the axis and by
convention by convention you know we'll
do the pz as the one along the axis
remember there's p x p y and pz
when we solve for the P orbitals right
those are the M's those are the M's
right one zero minus one now by
convention we put the pz along the
bonding axis
and you can see right away you know so
if I do this well I'm going to start
adding these wave functions
constructively and what you're going to
get
is let's see if I can draw this is
something that looks like that
and where this is actually going to be
plus and this is minus and notice that
I'm going to have nodes in there right I
had nodes in the original orbitals but I
got a lot of bonding in between
I got a lot of bonding density in
between that is a bonding orbital
that is a bonding orbital and and the
other thing we see about this is that it
is symmetric around that bondiacus so
it's actually a sigma pz orbital
it's a sigma we call it a sigma because
it's symmetric around the bonding axis
now if I were to take a px
oh well let's actually let's subtract
these
okay so minus plus minus
now
what you see is something very different
right so now oh boy can I draw this
Maybe
I don't know okay I'll take that
right and so now what you see so I'm
subtracting these and so the density
goes down and now you're going to get
minus minus right plus plus but but I've
reduced the electron density and even
worse I'm back to that situation where
right in between where I want to share
the most I'm saying no no probability
density there and that's an anti-bonding
Sigma p orbital so this would be Sigma
star pz okay Sigma star pz
now the other thing that you can do is
look at the the other directions right
and so I'll just take one of those
really quick and if you do that you see
something different right so now let's
combine these like this by the way some
textbooks
we're adding and subtracting we're
constructively interfering and
destructively interfering yeah so
sometimes you'll see a textbook ad like
this or add the other way which is
subtracting like this do the same thing
right you can decide how you want to
orient it but we're adding and
subtracting constructively and
destructively that's what we're doing
so I'm going to choose to add it like
this because then you just see if I do
this then those are going to have some
kind of overlap right
those are going to have some overlap of
plus up here and some overlap of minus
up down there and that is called a pi
orbital
yeah
yeah but if I subtracted them then what
you would see is something that looks
more like this
where you got that note in between again
right and this would be a pi star
orbital this would be for like PX
orbitals now notice these cannot be
sigmas
because
High orbital is not symmetric around the
bonding axis okay
these cannot be sigmas
but that's why we have another symbol
for them luckily we've got a lot of
symbols and the chemists are geniuses at
naming things and so these are called Pi
orbitals and as you can see that you
know okay I used our three p orbitals
one was I put it along the axis and I've
got two going you know perpendicular in
the other a plane and this is one of
them and then the other one would be you
know the other one p p y
so as you can see I'm going to have a
sigma a sigma star
two Pi orbitals and two Pi star orbitals
right
and then what we got to do is we got to
put them on our energy scale and instead
of going through drawing it all save
myself a few minutes here I'll show it
to you
all right so there's the energy scale
and oh they're pointing out the nodes
isn't that beautiful you can see right
here I had they're not saying what
molecule this is yet this is a 2p
orbital
and and it's pointing along the same
Bond axis right as the other one so this
is going to be a sigma p orbital this is
a sigma p orbital you can see that and
there's a sigma Star right good yeah if
we go to that there's the next one
there's a pi orbital and you get the
same exact effect you've got a lowering
of the energy because you're putting
electrons on the bond and a raising of
the energy because you're taking them
away
right
and that's what it looks like for the pi
orbital
and we can put it all together
and if you put it all together
what I want to do is put it together for
O2 and then show you a video and then do
my why this matters
now if you um put this together I'm
going to show you
the system for oxygen and nitrogen okay
and then we'll do one a couple other
cases too
but we're going to do oxygen first so if
I take oxygen
then
I've got my two I'm gonna I'm not even
going to write 1s anymore
that's way down in energy is not really
involved in the bonding I'm going to
leave it out
but I've got my oxygen
1s oxygen 1s okay
good so those are going to come in and
form molecular orbitals
like that and we know that they are all
filled okay now but on on now up here
I've got my oxygen sorry I just said I
wasn't going to do 1s and I'm not those
are 2s
those are 2s
Sigma 2s Sigma star 2s
okay good all right
oh let's see now over here I start with
my piece and I start with PX right p x p
y p z and in oxygen how many electrons
do I have in here so it's like this
everybody should be shouting
ah
that was so much better that was close
and then I've got I'm not gonna have
enough room I've got these over here
hmm p x p y p z
and there is oxygen
but you see now they come together
and they form these MOS and we just went
over what types they are right there's a
sigma p z orbital and there's a sigma
and but the ordering is about the same
thing
that we learned
which is that it has to do this Delta is
up there this Delta is up there
okay and so in that pz for oxygen you
can overlap more it it pushes those
apart more and so what you get is that
the pies are inside like that the pies
are inside
right so this would be I'm going to I'm
if I write in here it's going to get too
small so I'm going to do this this would
be a sigma
2p
Z
this would be a sigma 2pz star
and over here
these would be
Pi orbitals pi
p x
pi py and these
would be I almost can fit Pi star PX
and Pi star p y
all looking like the shapes that we've
been drawing right and then the filling
part comes from the filling of the AOS
right I've got my filling of the AOS
here I've got the valence filling for
oxygen there's the 1s down there right
and so I've got to put four electrons
from there and four electrons from here
into the middle so let's do that one two
three four five six seven eight Paulie
Paulie
right
so for oxygen
the bond order
if you add it up
the bo is two
it's a double bond we know that oh but
now we know so much more and this is
what I want to make
that Lewis could have gotten us this
but Lewis can't get us magnetism
Lewis can't get us magnetism molecular
orbital Theory can
okay and let me show you magnetism right
up close because if I take liquid
nitrogen that's not me though and I pour
it through a huge magnet I want that
magnet so badly but if I did that look
at that liquid nitrogen just goes right
on through and it's really fun to do
actually
um and so but there you go there that's
liquid nitrogen but what happens look at
liquid oxygen
liquid oxygen now you pour it through
and the magnet holds it in place
right whoa is right
there's four more things we got to cover
one is paramagnetism
another is something called mixing
another is what happens when you go
heteronuclear oh yeah
see what that means in a second and
finally
what I said I would get to which is
non-bonding which are not the same as
anti-bonding
what I'm covering right now there is
paramagnetism
because as you saw on the exam in one of
the questions we explained it we said if
you got unpaired electrons
if you got unpaired electrons then you
repair what does Paramount does it mean
it means that if you put a huge magnet
on it you respond you will feel a force
from that magnetic field
and so we did that in the exam we had a
silicon atom because we hadn't done
molecules but now we got molecules so I
can tell you why that experiment hap
what's happening I can tell you why the
experiment happens
really I didn't even know there was more
um
it happens because of Hun's rule
molecular orbitals and the fact that
I've got these two unpaired electrons in
the O2 molecule
and you know that in nitrogen those two
electrons are gone because nitrogen is
missing one more here and here so you've
got two less everything's filled
everything's filled paramagnetism now
now okay speaking of magnetism I
couldn't help but show you this this is
diamagnetism now diamagnetism everything
is filled but you still feel a little
repulsion to a magnetic field and some
of you may know there's this thing
called the ignoble prize only one person
in history has won both the ignoble and
the Nobel Prize Andre gaim who
discovered graphene with Scotch tape but
before that he won the ignoble prize
because he did this to frogs
because
water is diamagnetic and so it repels
the magnetic field it's just got to be
really really really high
um I hope that frog was okay
it looked sort of okay so if the frog is
floating and it's like a study about
levitation using magnetism why am i
showing that to you no particular reason
but this does get me to the why this
matters which has to do with how you
cook pasta and
of course
of course since we're talking about O2
but
when when I have finished cooking pasta
what do I do I pour it there it is
through it's like it's sophisticated I
pour it through a colander that's a
membrane
that's a membrane you did use a membrane
you did a filter now but I could also
have done that separation that same
separation I could have left it on the
stove I could have
and it would have boiled out all the
water and left me still with the pasta
separated from the water I've
accomplished the same exact thing I have
separated the pasta from the water
that's done
pasta may not taste as good but you've
done it but see the thing is that if you
separate things this way versus that way
you can just feel how much less energy
it's going to take in fact you can save
over 80 percent of the energy if you do
a membrane-based separation as opposed
to a thermal one
gesundheit
so those are two ways to separate
positive but see there's two ways to
separate lots of things
like how about one to ten nanometer
particles how about chemistry how about
molecules
how do you separate those
well you got the same two ways and if
you count up all the things we separate
this way it's a lot it goes on and on
and it will go all the way down the
infinite Corridor this is how we do
chemistry in fact if you have has anyone
seen this on the side of the road
that's a distillation column it's a big
pasta cooker
that's all you're doing is boiling one
molecule off of another
over a long time with a whole lot of
fossil fuel
in fact if you look at the U.S energy
consumption 30 roughly a third it goes
into industry 40 percent of that is for
this one thing it's boiling pasta but
the pasta is one nanometer to 10
nanometer particles
40 goes into boiling one chemical
species off of another separation
separation
that's
12 of all the energy that's the same as
every single drop of gasoline in every
single car truck and bus that's just to
give you a sense of how much energy that
is let me say well why aren't we using a
colander why don't we just pour it
through a condor like we do our boiling
pasta well we do that for one field
desalination I gotta why this matters on
that another time
but we don't do it for all those other
things and there's a really simple
reason we don't have the right pasta
colander
we don't
there's no option for that size scale
that can withstand the conditions
that are in all of those chemical
separations
but if we did this
we could we take so much O2 out of the
air we need O2 but we don't want the N2
so we have to separate how do we do it
we go cryogenic we go to very very cold
temperatures which is the same as
boiling
right you're lower but you're still
spending all this fossil fuel to lower
the temperature
that's how much O2 we generate each year
right and this is how much energy it
takes it's like half a percent of all
U.S energy just to get but what if
you could use something like o2's
paramagnetism what if you could use
something about the chemistry of o2 to
do this separation
more efficiently lower energy or maybe
make a new colander that does that
and if any of you have ideas come talk
to me
foreign
this is a problem I care a lot about
okay bye but I had some other pair of
magnetism one pair of electrons we got
that one ha
ha why is chemistry not why can't they
follow the rules
why but they they always got to break
them
and what we see well this was oxygen
Sigma Sigma s
igma Sigma Stars Pi Pi star but look at
what happens for nitrogen ha why because
of something some people like to call
mixing all it says remember I said that
that if we where did that somewhere I
said
that The Closer an energy or the closer
in symmetry orbitals are the more
overlap they can have and the more they
interact and can mix together in the
ways that I've been talking about
yeah well it turns out that if you go
below oxygen in what are called
homonuclear dimers which is where the
atoms are the same
then you can get mixing even between
this Sigma and that Sigma
and so what happens is instead of them
being kind of separate like this for N2
there's an interaction
you see you can think about the same way
I'm throwing more orbitals into the mix
and and so because they can contribute
to overlapping you're changing that
Delta e even more that's effectively
what's happening
and so you can see this one for nitrogen
goes down but that one goes up because
that's the Delta e because it's able to
mix in
able to mix in because they have the
same Symmetry and they're closer for
those smaller atoms they're a lot closer
in energy
and so if you look at this what happens
is those switch
they switch it's real
they switch now it doesn't change the
thing I just talked about which is the
magnetic properties of N2 because
they're still all filled
but it is important because if I were to
pull an electron out of o2 I mean out of
N2 it would come from a sigma orbital
not a pi orbital
because of those interactions those
happen below O2 so this is from your
textbook and you see it says 2s2pz
interaction remember 2pz is Sigma Sigma
same symmetry able to mix don't mix very
well here but here they're strong enough
to to change the ordering of that
orbital and that orbital right see that
that's an important effect
okay
all right
now
um so but it only happens below O2 it
happens below O2 because that's where
those energies uh and orbitals can line
up in that way
now there's two okay so we just covered
that now there's two more things
two more things
and then that's all of Mo Theory
one is I've been giving you the same
atoms but what if we go from a homolink
nuclear diameter to a heteronuclear
diameter which just means one is one and
one is another type of atom
how do we draw an ml diagram for that
and the second thing is what happens
the second thing
is what happens in this case in HCL H is
bringing Only One S electron to the
party but CL is bringing all the is
bringing s is bringing P what does it do
right how does the mo diagram look in
that case where I've got all these extra
electrons coming in from one of the
atoms right now I will not do this in 30
seconds but I will next week give you a
nice sort of thorough explanation for
each of these two last Mo cases in the
meantime have a very good weekend